you might be starting your day this
morning with a plate of pancakes or
waffles ances are your dousing them in
maple syrup I'm getting hungry
alright it's a 300 million dollar
industry and some people call it liquid
gold Vermont farmers are facing
increased competition from large
corporations and artificially flavored
corn syrup Don Dahler met one family
using technology to preserve their
cherished tradition Don good morning
good morning every year when winter
loosens its grip sugar farmers hike into
the woods and tap thousands of trees it
takes up to 60 gallons of sap to make
one gallon of syrup
the ultimate renewable resource maple
trees produce sugar four to six weeks a
year
potentially for hundreds of years but it
only takes a taste to know that's a
sweet deal how old do you think these
things are 100 years off for 75 winters
Dave Silla weighs family has been making
maple syrup to me but that's just my
guess this is how they used to do it
when he was a boy with hand drills and
hammers horses and sleds and thousands
of buckets that had to be emptied
multiple times a day if the SAP was
really flowing sounds like hard work
it was Hara comes there she goes a taste
of it enough to get any sweetness or not
yeah you can definitely older the tree
the sweeter the SAP so older is better
yeah business yes it's the sound of
money dropping into the bottom of the
pail how many trees do you think you
were working back then probably 812
thousand trees Vermont is the largest
maple syrup reducer in the US with every
fourth tree in the state being a maple
there's plenty of natural resources for
big and small businesses which now
produce more than 1.3 million gallons of
syrup a year the scylla ways have always
been primarily dairy farmers it's kind
of a science tapping the tree but a few
years ago Dave's nephew Paul Lambert
took it upon himself to sweeten their
family fortunes by taking their syrup
operation from hobby to big business it
was a side business for a long time and
now it's more of an income producer for
your family right yeah it's important to
us drills and hammers replaced by miles
of plastic tubes tapped into 6,200 trees
that's just pouring in there though that
is a lot of SAP coming out of this tree
there's a lot of SAP high-tech equipment
takes the clear sound boils it down
which produces the liquid syrup 70 solar
panels subsidize the energy costs of the
entire operation we produce about 40
gallons an hour over this rig 40 gallons
an hour yeah and a total of around 3,000
a year to 3500 gallons and before you
modernize the system what were you
producing somewhere around three to five
hundred gallons syrup wow that's a big
difference according to a recent study
maple farmers fear over production but
are also worried about climate change
winters in Vermont are getting warmer
earlier the first two is the enlarged
would be when we tap the trees now we
should tap the trees the first week of
February a month earlier to get more of
the days when it's above freezing during
the daytime and freezing at night for
SAP flows for now
tapping earlier often means longer more
profitable seasons but a warm snap can
shut things down quickly still when the
sap is flowing and the entire family is
working almost around the clock they
always take the time to count their
blessings and thank the humble maple
tree the gift that keeps on giving for
someone who doesn't live up here and do
this what's the best thing about this
business the warm days seeing the SAP
flow out of the tree yeah taste of fresh
maple syrup not bad not bad
studies at the University of Rhode
Island found that maple syrup contains
beneficial compounds similar to those in
green tea red wine and berries although
the scientists couldn't say definitively
if its overall healthier and white
now sit on a pancake with butter is that
so healthy that's if it makes you happy
I think it's healthy never gonna run out
of that stuff either are they it's like
up there and you found the perfect
subject yeah he came out of central
casting you gotta wear one of those hats
if you're getting me
I like the check shirt alright Don thank
you